[Musique]
j'te fais pas
[Applaudissements]
alors déjà benjamin
comment vous avez eu l'idée quand vous
êtes dit je vais faire cette vidéo je ne
suis pas dans
cette vidéo non on était tous les deux
avec une amie brown est passé devant une
église et ouais je pense qu'on avait
besoin d'eux où je prends voulait
rigoler sur les deux y avait pas de
préparation où les rigoler faire cette
vidéo dans les rigoles et il y avait un
pas le message derrière il ya un an de
base c'était même temps la poste de bast
juste on va danser dans l'église ont
fait la vidéo c'était super légers vous
étiez seul et on était seuls n'avait pas
la musique
bien sûr mais personne n'y a personne
qui vous a vu aller visiter les termes
en visionnant personne n'est d'accord et
vous êtes dit tiens on va faire un
délire dans la terre navets de ouais bon
alors là c'est au début il y avait pas
l'intention de la piste et alors on
c'est vrai que une église c'est juste
parce que vous êtes passés devant ouais
c'était le but c'était juste de rigoler
pour vous ce n'était pas prémédité sur
s'était pas préparé prévu de faire cette
vidéo est ce que est ce que l'on va
faire un petit peu le tour des des
chroniqueurs on va interroger également
son avocat est ce que toi tu as eu
conscience que ça pouvait choquer au
moment où tu l'as fait je suppose que
non puisque tu me l'a dit mais après tu
t'es rendu compte du déferlement
étais-tu tennis ça c'est vrai que
peut-être durée j'aurais pas dû la faire
ou pas du tout donc là c'était
impossible de concevoir le fait que cela
puisse enfin ça puisse être vu par moi
tu peux pas dire ça mais c'est sûr après
une saison où l'attendent différentes
une fois que les poster c'était beaucoup
plus réfléchi et je dénonce est quelque
chose en la postant et le rendre public
parce que c'est moi qui décide de
dénoncer quoi qu'est-ce que j'ai donc
c'est quand tu quand tu apprécies tu la
possibilité par tu voulais pas la rendre
publique je connaissais le faire voilà
pourquoi
depuis que sur les réseaux du commun
c'est presque 2 ans 1/2 ans que je me
sois très souvent des gens qui pensent
que je devrais rentrer dans le droit
chemin que dieu devait guider on va
souvent faire appel à l'abolition depuis
le début parce que je suis ce que j'ai
j'ai des relations avec des hommes quand
le surtout par rapport à ça d'ailleurs
ou parce que je m'habillais que les
vêtements féminins enfin provient de
sujets
et là j'avais envie de faire un peu un
affront à tous et à toutes les
réflexions que j'avais par rapport à la
religion dans ce texte alors j'ai pas
les saisies fini si non je crois j'ai le
choix que c'est tout en fait c'était
quoi en réaction à toutes les insultes
ou les tous des jeunes me remarque le
dénonçait je voulais surtout dénoncer
l'homophobie qui est et sera présenté
dans la l'église oui d'accord mais à
présent je me sers depuis deux ans une
histoire compliquée en plus un jardin
vouziers venir vu venir témoigner en
pour autre chose vous reviendrez
certainement d'en parler parce que c'est
c'est un triste sujet
mais ce soir je vois qu'il ya énormément
de bruit que benjamin castaldi et s'il
vous plaît timing est alors je voudrais
d'abord quelqu'un qui a été choqué
quelqu'un de mesuré un guillaume genton
non mais en fait on a le sentiment que
vous faites une partie d'une génération
pour qui existait sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est tellement important est
reconnue faire des like que vous êtes
prêts à faire n'importe quoi quitte à
faire une vidéo qui peut offenser des
gens toute une communauté une religion
et ça a été même perçu par certains
comme du blasphème là votre explication
elle est intéressante et je pense que ce
que vous revendiquez c'est très
intéressant mais je pense qu'il peut
être d'autres manières de le faire et on
pourra aussi parler de vous on pourra
aussi vous inviter sur des plateaux là
on a la sensation en plus vous l'assumez
vous écrivez en croupe top à l'église
donc vous savez que ça va choquer vous
savez que ça va provoquer et on a la
sensation vous voulez faire ça
uniquement pour faire le buzz et vous
oubliez que ça peut choquer et orthez
des gens après ce qui est super
important aussi de dire c'est que c'est
les gens qui décident de donner la
tension à chacun des sujets qu'ils
regardent enfin c'est aussi une forte de
fait attention à ce que vous faites chez
rézo lapied une vidéo la partager la
commenter elle a regardé ça un impact et
ça fera que d'autres personnes la
regarderont c'est pas moi qui la regarde
à dire que vous attendiez parce que ça
choque les gens vous avez fait ça pour
choquer les gens vous l'assumez que ça
choque les gens voyaient quitter un
décalage entre l'église et d'un goûter
jeux mais je m'en doutais que ça allait
créer un peu à la discorde
d'après ce qu'on me dit si vous vous
baladiez dans la rue donc comme veiller
avec un ami et après avoir consommé
quelques substances illégales
oui c'est vrai voilà et où vous êtes dit
viens on va faire les chipies dans une
église
vous aviez déjà côtoyé entre octobre
dans les rues de marseille voilà juste
quelqu'un d'autre qui est qui est choqué
béatrice
hess que alors j'ai deux questions
est-ce que vous auriez osé faire la même
chose dans une synagogue ou dans une
mosquée est ma deuxième question c'est y
at il un lieu qui existe dans lequel
vous n'auriez pas osé faire ça et lequel
je crois pas qu'il y ait eu lieu dans
lequel je vais pas de le faire mais j'ai
essayé de ne pas le faire dans une
mosquée dans une synagogue parce que je
trouve que c'est une religion qui est
trop facilement et rapidement surtout en
france et partout partout d'ailleurs
attaqué et enfin c'est constamment cette
religion qui a attaqué dès qu'on
critique et cora baisse et la danse la
faune que je faisais c'était à
l'invasion chrétienne alors moi je
trouve que alors au moi je vous dis je
trouve que toutes les religions à
baisser mois ce que disait avoir foi
dans une interview qui est je trouve que
c'est bien aussi les gens qui disent que
moi j'aime bien ils ont qui revendique
le fait d'aller à l'église d'être
chrétien c'est vrai que c'est une
religion aussi je trouve on entend alors
que c'est la première religion en france
on en parle moins que les autres
religions et je trouve qu'il ya moi
j'aime bien les gens qui revendiquent le
fait d'être d'être voilà là naîtra
d'être religieux est d'aller à l'église
dimanche matin à ce que je disais dans
la foi et je trouve que c'est quelque
chose aussi qui se perd et je trouve
qu'il ya un non respect moi je trouve de
l'église qui me dérange vraiment
rappelle même du pape de l'église tout
ça ça me dérange j'avais vu je l'avais
dit à l'époque quand élise lucet avait
cartonné le le pape moi ça va forcément
choqué voilà je trouve que ces voix là
il ya quand même un spa voir et au
niveau de la religion catholique je
trouve qu'au contraire comme
en mine de rien on se dit il y aura
moins de retombées c'est vrai qu'on se
permet plus de choses et je trouve que
c'est ça ça me dérange aussi mathieu
finale maintenant j'ai ainsi d'accord
j'ai mis non j'espère que je passe ce
que trop de gens à l'antenne mais est-ce
que gère pas là c'est que j'ai juste
touché par ce garçon parce que il faut
comprendre quelque chose c'est que bien
sûr c'est extrêmement choquant mais
derrière tout ça est derrière de deux
gamins qu'on compte peut-être fait une
bêtise il ya un petit message entendre
qu'ils aient bien sûr ne pas critiquer
l'église catholique ait jamais de la vie
mais qui est que comme vous dire que moi
je suis catholique et comme ce garçon
j'ai la même sexualité pendant jusqu'à
et que la profession de foi pendant 15
ans on vous dit tous les jours tous les
jours qu'être homosexuel c'est mal que
vous êtes rejeter que vous ne serez pas
dans la maison de dieu qui vous ferment
à la porte que vous ne pourra jamais
vous marier à l'époque c'est tout ce que
vous entendez et pendant quinze d'un
temps on vous dit tu es quelqu'un de mal
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps alors ça avance un petit peu ça
avance doucement moi il m'a fallu près
40 ans pour deux pour accepter le fait
d'être catholique donc oui ils sont
jeunes je trouve très touchant ce garçon
alors bien sûr c'est très maladroit il
dicte des substances tout ça mais je
pense qu'il faut peut-être aller un
petit pot de au delà du coût de ce qu'on
vient de voir et de ce qui peut choquer
les gens et je l'entends encore une fois
et peut-être de comprendre le message
aussi que deux gamins dont je sais pas
quel âge as-tu de 18 ans un gamin de 18
ans mais voilà aujourd'hui souffrent de
ne pas être reconnu par une religion